الانهيار العسكري لبوتين، نتلقى مقطع
فيديو جديدًا الليلة لمعركة مميتة
اندلعت في معسكر للجيش بالقرب من موسكو
وفقًا لوسائل الإعلام الروسية، وكان هؤلاء الرجال
على وشك إرسالهم إلى الخطوط الأمامية،
ثم يقال إن أحد الجنود هنا
انزعج  وبحسب ما ورد تعرض رؤسائه
للضرب على أيدي أفراد من
وحدة الاستطلاع والشرطة العسكرية،
وبعد ذلك اندلعت مشاجرة جماعية
بالسكاكين
ومات
رجل هناك، قبل أن يصل حتى إلى
الخطوط الأمامية في أوكرانيا، لكن هذه
الفوضى هذه  هذا النوع من
الشجار أعني أن هذا هو بالضبط ما
كان يتحدث عنه الجنرال الروسي الكبير إيفان بوبوف
عندما تحدث بعد أن تم
فصله لانتقاده استعدادات بوتين للحرب
كما قال العديد من قادة
أفواج الفرق إنهم يفعلون ذلك لجنود
القوات المسلحة الروسية.  لم تتمكن أوكرانيا من
اختراق جيشنا من الأمام،
فضربنا قائدنا الكبير من
الخلف غدرًا وحقيرًا
وقطع رأس الجيش في
أصعب اللحظات وأكثرها كثافة،
ولا نعرف شيئًا عما
حدث لبوبوف منذ أن أرسل ذلك
أعني ذلك  قال إنه من الواضح أنه
طُرد لكنك تعرف مكان وجوده
وحالته الجسدية، ولا نعرف أننا نعرف أن
الكرملين يرفض تلك
التعليقات الصادرة عن نافذة منبثقة للجنرال على الرغم من أنه
بالطبع ليس أول جنرال
يخالف بوتين ويدفع غرامة  السعر مرة أخرى
كما قلت، نحن نعلم أنه تم فصله
ولا نعرف ماذا إذا كان هناك أي شيء أبعد من
ذلك